today on our show Oh spider-man old
coming trailer this year it's funny
men's homecoming and me and Mark we're
just coming in we're gonna watch it
fresh you're gonna watch our fresh
reaction trick seeing it live for the
first time right here today right now on
fat man I'm back
we're Piplup with women
[Music]
[ __ ] the fat man Oh Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I am luck Bernard okay man
spider-man homecoming trailer just
dropped mere seconds ago
yes minutes ago we'll be honest and me
and Mark haven't watched it yet nope oh
here we were recording family my bad
minutes so we said let's live react to
it so we're watching it fresh and you're
gonna watch us react to this video with
virgin oh yeah because I was like let's
watch it first and just see what it is
we can be prepared he's like no no we
are going to be Veritate I said we're
going in [ __ ] dry Sun nice that's how
we're gonna do it it was like was that
me and then I explained and he was like
okay okay let's work up to dry after it
was no prize a word while we're doing it
this is the first time you're seeing us
see it fresh I know unvarnished this is
how the director is the director of the
directed cop car I believe so
and I can't remember off the top of my
head and of course the stars Tom Holland
who was in Marvel's captain America high
3 : Civil War they left the area they
did but we know we know and he was
amazing this is my favorite spider-man
portrayal on film to date this may
supersede my favorite spider-man
portrayal of all time spider-man and his
amazing friends wow really
oh my god they never got that character
more right than on that show you sure
it's not that Nick Hammond 78 TV series
I was close it was close
famous man big the tech on that show was
good the show didn't last long at the
end you know what he said mmm so long if
you know who that kid is that's kind of
a music I get it got a much more
generous laugh than the desert back you
know that's how we roll all right this
is it folks I'm excited man we've never
like watched a trailer to get how it's
gonna go yeah this is weird this is like
you know we've never tried anal this is
like you know stuck in a marriage of
sorts
yeah have you gone to movies together
but those movies didn't have trailers
and screenings and shoot goes right into
the movie but all right here we go folks
dial it up it's about to start we've got
the home screen right there you know
this is the Marvel homecoming the marvel
spiderman homecoming official trailer
it's about to start
oh you'll hear it mmm and here we go
five four three homecoming you know I'm
coming here we go
Oh coming
Benji oh it's all over my eyes I win
full of [ __ ] and eyes perfect good
lizallen
don't do anything I would do and
definitely don't do anything I wouldn't
do
there's a little gray area in there and
that's where you operate
no not nah this is just costume this
awesome what forget the flying monster
guy there are people who handle this
they gave him an armored
oh yes oh [ __ ] yes whip whip aah you see
him [ __ ] side-by-side with stark
let's watch it again dude that was
awesome
one more time one more time one more
time
do it again dude it go webs webs under
his arms Queens they're robbing a bank
in Queens with lasers how do they get
[ __ ] lasers the lasers appear later
on Avengers instead Avengers oh my god
the eyes perfection and dude it's high
school they did that for like a minute
in the other movie skirt probably stop
staring is creepy though
yes or losers trials don't do anything I
would do and definitely don't do
anything I wouldn't do
there's a little gray area in there and
that's where you are tomorrow movie
there's always somebody shown up
that's Nedley instrument oh that's
[ __ ] uh badass oh that's [ __ ] dope
flying monster guy there are people who
handle the valves in the bunker
oh my god dude that rocks so hard step
on fairy that's what he's holding
together huh come on oh my god I want to
cry I can't believe we live in a world
where they just shoved [ __ ] spider-man
and Iron Man swinging through Queens to
go god damn it that's perfect
Oh absol it was [ __ ] fantastic fun
and so smart to like set it in high
school but like that's [ __ ]
old-school spider-man that's like it
goes by management doesn't buddy and
[ __ ] where and if he said Liz and that's
lizallen like that's going deep cuts
isn't it my yeah amazing you're not
gonna have Gwen you're not gonna have
Mary Jane mad at Mary Jane we're all
sitting across from them you said you
guys are such losers could be Mary Jane
oh my god oh my god I'm gonna cry do you
mean Wow
don't get my hopes up stead of making
her like you know [ __ ] like the prom
queen homecoming queen please be that
you know what it don't have to be that
but like do you know how [ __ ] awesome
that would be if that was that if she
was also a misfit but like the smoker
the girls room misfit you made me cry
are such a good writer
I'm afraid you might be a better writer
on them I don't I hope you're [ __ ]
right man god damn it that would be
amazing they don't say to like the end
of the movie don't like what your name
Mary Jane oh my god what would like a
dress up would like a less deep voice
though yeah weird yeah like a high
school girl what did she say in the
comics she's like you just hit the
jackpot a singer face it you're just a
dick huh oh it's you know what dude that
that was amazing but it's gonna it's
gonna ding just a little bit when it's
not [ __ ] I am I showed us something
beautiful
um that is fantastic [ __ ] that looks
great yeah when is that coming out seven
seven seventeen there's something to
live for so you got whens guard
and that is I think both this summer
they're both this summer Guardians is
OMA or so once before the other yeah
once a Sony movie ones the Disney right
but now they're in bed with each other
yeah I think we get thor ragnarok in may
you get Spidey in July and then you get
guardians in August I mean I know
everyone's like this [ __ ] next year
is gonna suck but not for movies no and
then Wonder Woman is in there also and
then Justice League is October oh my god
dude I'm literally living from movie to
movie 17 but if they can line him up
like that for the next four years I mean
just like trace possibly eight I might
not even you know hey dude like thirty
years is gonna be in our life of just
like five of these a year [ __ ] yes and
then let's also not forget episode eight
is next November and now yeah that's
right you got a Star Wars movie here and
I remember do something it's crazy how
like they've really given I'm about
anybody else but me personally a
reasonable is [ __ ] to see now goddamn it
is exciting and then 2018 we get Black
Panthers stop it my [ __ ] them yes I'm
dick I'm solo stop it's never ending
never wasn't good coming see listen hell
of a time to be a lot it really is like
I weep for my dead father man like he
lived in an era where he didn't have
this [ __ ] you got one Star Wars movie
over three years if you were lucky I
wonder if like whoever like I spawn like
I had a kid then maybe she one day has
kids and they have kids or something
like that if they'll be like those poor
old [ __ ] they only had movies and they
have some other [ __ ] experience for
spider-man you become spider-man that's
the movie pay like [ __ ] 400 bucks I
love how you think that the zombie
robots won't have already taken my
children's children's children are we
talking about well I like to be more
hopeful I'm hopeful until the apocalypse
comes and then any minute now prepared
but you know what this so got those
[ __ ] flicks toll can we do if we're
gonna go down screaming we're gonna down
screaming spider
he can't take those away no no nobody
can no nobody can take away but Kevin
Feige gives us I mean that's it I mean
that's that
that doesn't happen without him oh that
reeks of in a best possible way of
[ __ ] Kevin buggies fingerprints like
that everything that I am drawn to about
that feels like that's the guy that's
mixing the brew over in the [ __ ]
kitchen yeah smells like it I don't
think anybody's a night I think that was
actually oh yeah for sure
he was absolutely like this is but I
take another away from the dragger that
looks fantastic
like it looks like a John Hughes movie
it really does in the best way
yeah with [ __ ] heroics oh my god
[ __ ] Webb wings dude you know what
I'm saying it's all bit go do the REO
did your dick go hard my dick you can do
better than that
there it is folks man you watched us
watch that twice [ __ ] yeah we'll do it
more but not with you here yeah we're
gonna keep going thanks for hanging out
with us here fat man I'm Batman I'm
Kevin Smith I'm open guard come back and
watch us watch some other [ __ ] later on
man same fats on same fat channel
SModcast calm or youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith
[Music]
you